well when the church was smaller I had
people in our home all the time the
first year of the church back in
nineteen eighty i think we had maybe 125
people and i had each one of those
people in in our home for dinner that
first year and the first probably seven
years of the church i would do a
christmas open house I'd start baking in
October's stuff everything in my freezer
in our neighbors freezers and then do
this open house for all the parishioners
and when it got to about 800 people
coming through my little 1,200 square
foot home i kind of reached my max I
couldn't do it anymore so I don't have
as much contact on that that kind of
where people are in my home bases we
actually do that more with with our
staff which has several we have several
hundred people on our staff so we'll
have the staff in our home for different
events I I work a lot with our staff
wives their husbands are on staff to
spend a lot of time with them and we
make ourselves available on the weekends
we're not the kind of people that just
stay behind closed doors if you know if
I'm there at a service I'm out on the
patio talking to people praying with
people shaking hands hugging kissing
babies I love to smell bake newborn
baby's head so people always bring them
in their baby gold as well as that so I
just I loved I loved to be around those
newborn babies so I I think that we're
really relational and we like to stay in
close contact as much as we can with the
churches as big as we are
you